[Music]
for me reinvention is constantly pushing
yourself constantly learning and just
evolving over the course of your career
but also over the course of your life
[Music]
I'm from a small town in Oklahoma and as
I was growing up really the options I
saw for for being a successful
professional were be a doctor be a
lawyer or go into oil and gas and so
when I went to the University of
Oklahoma
I majored in petroleum engineering
because I loved math and science
fast forward to 27 years old i
co-founded a battery metals mining
company and so now instead of just
working in oil and gas and working in
the status quo I'm working to continue
pushing boundaries in to expedite that
energy transition
something that was surprising about
being in a first-time entrepreneur and a
co-founder of Black Mountain metals was
just how much you get in your own head
you know when I first got on the
airplane from Fort Worth Texas to Perth
Australia by myself to go found a
battery metals mining company the only
thing going through my mind was actually
what have you gotten yourself into who
do you think you are you're just going
to lose all of your investors money and
so you know just that level of
confidence that you have to have in
yourself and conviction not the idea
you're chasing is right with something
that you know I knew I had to have it
but truly the level that entrepreneurs
have to take it to is entirely different
[Music]
navigating natural resources as a woman
you have to identify your champions
early on and not everyone will be your
supporter but it's so important to just
look past those people outwork them and
prove that wrong I view myself as
someone who is pushing the limits on
ensuring we're going to be set up for a
cleaner future I see myself as a
successful woman within natural
resources and so because I'm
representing these things and I'm taking
action not just talking about it I think
I'm enacting greater change
you